Part D given that F of 1 is equal to 3
write an expression for F f of X that
involves an integral since it involves
an integral we can assume that's going
to involve F prime somehow especially
since they've given us so much
information about F prime including its
graph and the area under above the curve
at different intervals and then they
want us to find F of 4 and F of negative
2 so let's think about how we can
connect how we can connect F prime and
integral and f of X well if we took the
integral from A to B of F prime of f
prime of X DX what is this going to be
equal to well this is going to be equal
to the antiderivative of F prime of X
which is f of X and you're going to
evaluate that at B and a and subtract
the difference so this is going to be F
of B minus F of a this is straight out
of the fundamental theorem of calculus
all right this is interesting
well what instead of instead of having a
B what if we had an X there and if we're
gonna put an X as one of our bounds of
integration well we'll use a different
variable for our integration here so let
me write it this way so if I have the
integral from a to X of f prime of u D U
well what is this going to be equal to
well this is going to be by the same
logic the antiderivative of this
evaluated at X so f of X minus F of a
minus F of a or if we wanted to solve
for f of X we could add F of a to both
sides and we would get f of X is equal
to the integral from a to X of F prime
of u D U and once again why did I pick u
I just needed some letter other than X
since I already used X as one of my
bounds of integration and I'm adding F
of a to both sides I swap I swap the
sides two so f of X is going to be equal
to this plus F of a plus F of a so this
this is a general form if a is a lower
bound but they gave us some information
they said that F of 1 F of 1 is equal to
3
so if we choose a to be equal to one if
you say this is one right over here this
is one then we know that this is going
to be equal to three so we can write f
of X f of X is equal to the integral I'm
using one is my a since I know what f of
1 is from 1 to X of f prime of u D u
plus F of 1 they told us what that is
that is going to be equal to 3 so this
is the first part right here we just did
it that is the first part of the problem
now let's try to find f of 4 and F of
negative 2 all right
F of 4 well wherever C the next we
substitute of 4 there's going to be
integral from 1 to 4 of f prime of u D U
plus 3 so what is going to be the
integral from 1 to 4 of F prime of UD u
so let's look up here so the integral
from 1 to 4 of F prime that's that curve
right over here well that's going to
give this area but it's going to be the
negative of the area because it's the if
you just take the integral it's the it's
the area that you could view above the
x-axis and below or 4 think in terms of
view up up the U axis and below the
below the function what is the other way
around the function is below the
horizontal axis here so this area which
they told us in the problem the area
bounded by the x-axis and the graph of F
prime over the interval 1 4 is 12 so
this area over here is 12 but the
integral is going to be a negative
because once again our function is below
the x-axis so this integral this right
over here is going to be a negative 12
this is negative 12 so negative 12 plus
3 is negative 9 all right now let's
evaluate F of negative 2 F of negative 2
is equal to the integral from 1 to
negative 2
of F prime of u D U plus 3 what's kind
of feels a little strange to have a the
upper bound to be
lower than the lower bound so we can
swap the bounds and then add a negative
out here so this is going to be equal to
the negative of if we swap if we swap
the bounds here so from negative 2 to 1
f prime of U D U plus 3 so what's the
integral from negative 2 to 1 well they
give us that from negative 2 to 1 they
told us that this area over here is 9
but once again because it's below the
horizontal axis and above the curve we
would say that the or the integral will
evaluate to be negative 9 so the area is
9 but once again the the curve is below
the x-axis so the integral would give us
negative 9 so this would evaluate to
negative 9 so you take the negative of
negative 9 which is positive 9 plus 3
which is equal to so 9 plus 3 is equal
to 12 and we're done